[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 recibimos en nuestros estudios a una
mujer abogada militante feminista y
profundamente de izquierdas y que cuenta
cada vez más en el debate público
francés porque se ha convertido en el
estandarte de la lucha contra el capacit
ismo enseguida veremos que es además se
acaba de publicar su primera novela
mister t
hoy hace escala en parís la
franco-chilena elisa rojas elisa
muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros y bienvenida hola elisa nace en
santiago de chile en 1979 y siendo
pequeña su familia se traslada a vivir a
francia es en parís donde vive se forma
estudia y se convierte en abogada va en
silla de ruedas porque nació con una
enfermedad rara genética que se llama
osteogénesis imperfecta también llamada
enfermedad de los huesos de cristal y
que tiene como consecuencia que se
debiliten los huesos y que se bloqueé el
crecimiento no sé si ha explicado
y si a ver vamos a empezar por una
pregunta que es el capacit ismo y por
qué lucha contra el el capacit ismo yo
diría que es un sistema de opresión que
elige las personas sin discapacidad en
norma y que se intuye una jerarquía
entre los cuerpos y los seres humanos
entonces ellos luchó contra él porque me
parece que es un problema de desigualdad
y de injusticia un problema político que
obvió meter esa
en 2016 confunda el colectivo lucha y
discapacidad por la igualdad y la
emancipación en su manifiesto denuncian
la institucionalización como única
respuesta a las necesidades reales o
supuestas de las personas con
discapacidad
esto supone dicen una segregación social
y espacial explíquenos esto quiere decir
que francia aparca en instituciones a
personas con discapacidad y las y las
segrega si yo pienso que las personas
con discapacidad tienen que vivir como
nosotros
o con la familia o en su propia casa
pero no en lugares especiales que no
tienen sentido además esos lugares ahora
todo el mundo lo sabe que son peligrosos
que son lugares donde hay muchos abusos
de todo tipo y el problema es que en
francia no quieren salir de ese sistema
quien muy malo y que tienen una visión
de la discapacidad que biomédica
y me parece que hay que salir de esa
visión
y hace una edición social de la
discapacidad en eso tiene que ver mucho
la adaptación de la movilidad por
ejemplo si se infantiliza las personas
con discapacidad
por ejemplo usted se opone a que haya
asistentes sexuales para las personas
con discapacidad y finalmente es como si
se las considerara que no son adultas en
las relaciones amorosas incluso que son
asexuales sí eso me parece un problema y
por supuesto las personas con
discapacidad son infantilizada y sobre
todas las mujeres cuando esta vez era
porque allí son infantilizar como
mujeres y como mujeres con discapacidad
es doble maltrato y doble
infantilización
cuando toma conciencia de todo esto es
un período muy particular es en la
facultad de derecho en la sorbona allí
nace una historia de amor frustrada que
acaba de plasmar en su primera novela
autobiográfica mister t é moi mister y
yo en la editorial maga bu una podríamos
decir comedia romántica llena de humor y
muy muy politizada en la que se vuela
por los aires los prejuicios y
estereotipos y en este libro éste cuenta
la historia del amor que usted siente
por un amigo
del que se enamora y que es un amigo no
un amor no correspondido no y escribe
desde el primer día le amo y él no me
ama porque decide escribir este libro
porque lo que me interesaba era explicar
cómo funciona el capacit ismo en las
relaciones afectivas amorosas y sexuales
me parecía muy importante pues porque es
un tema que es maltratado por los
periodistas yo pienso y quería mostrar
dónde están los verdaderos problemas y
quería escribir un libro lo que sea en
poder que que me puede dar a las mujeres
con discapacidad e incluso a todas las
mujeres porque yo pienso que es un libro
que todo el mundo pueda leer
por encima de la mesa algo muy muy
simple no y voy a leer un extracto de su
libro lo voy a traducir porque porque
está en francés y dice mi madre me dijo
que buscará un hombre en silla de ruedas
tal vez el chico con discapacidad en
cuestión tiene ganas de tener elección
de elegir porque no podríamos tener
elección porque no podríamos tener la
posibilidad de elegir tiene una
respuesta ahora a esta pregunta que
plantea en el libro yo pienso que
tenemos que tener elección que tenemos
derecho también a tener elección
todo el mundo tiene elección
es más la sociedad que pondría barreras
entonces eso
de una pregunta mister te lo ha leído
este libro estaría bien no tener
igualdad en su versión está que todo el
mundo me hace y no sé no no tengo la
respuesta y me interesa nenas que la
gente de saber si lo a leer o no
en el libro porque se hablan de muchas
cosas habla de ese amor no correspondido
pero se pone encima de la mesa muchas
cuestiones y nuevamente dado se pregunta
me gusta maquillarme soy una mala
feminista y yo le pregunto a usted una
feminista no puede maquillarse donde se
sitúa dentro del feminismo era una broma
por supuesto a lo mejor soy una mala
feminista quien seduce
pero obviamente lo que pienso es que no
es importante la apariencia física de
una mujer para saber eso lo más
importante es saber qué ideas dentro del
feminismo ella defiende
es muy activa en las redes sociales y
últimamente twitter francia ha
suspendido cuentas de feministas por
publicar la siguiente pregunta que se
puede hacer para que los hombres dejen
de violar es peligroso que haya esa
censura que una empresa privada
bloqueé cuentas censura me parece que sí
es muy hipócrita porque el problema es
que cuando los hombres amenazan o
insultan a las mujeres en las redes
sociales a las feministas no les pasa
nada y cuando la feminista pregunta y
hacen una pregunta es simplemente muy
importante además
en suspender la cuenta eso me parece
me parece grosero y peligroso
hipócrita del parte de twitter no son la
foto del capacit ismo y del machismo
sino también muy pugna cigarrera contra
el presidente francés emmanuel mccomb al
que se opone con frecuencia no sé si hay
una especie de rabia resentimiento de
donde nace o si es por la visión de que
tiene el gobierno francés de las
personas con discapacidad
primero es un nombre de derecha y yo no
soy de derecha me llevo una publicidad
que es muy violenta ha sido puro regreso
sobre regreso y ahora en esta crisis me
da rabia por supuesto de ver que no es
capaz de tomar decisiones importantes la
gente se está muriendo y no tenía
máscara ahora no tiene suficiente vacuna
si no sabe qué hacer me parece que tiene
que a lo mejor cambiar de barry agregó
está puesto se ha entrevistado alguna
vez con él lo conoce no no no sabía con
un no me gusta ya para nada entre stern
y con él no me interesa yo sé el a decir
sí señorita que lo entiendo muy bien
pero no va a cambiar la política que
hace entonces no no tengo el tiempo que
me quede con que políticos o políticas
se identifica más yo diría por ejemplo
alexandría ocasio cortes
en francia danielle hubo no y si para
elegir hombres diría salvador allende
por supuesto llevar a nuestro cristo
pero el problema es que yo no conozco
supuestamente bien la política chilena
reciente para tener un hombre es menos
histórico y más reciente y justamente
cuál es su relación con chile donde
últimamente hubo un movimiento feminista
muy muy importante se convirtió en viral
justo antes de la pandemia con contra
los violadores cuál es su relación con
me encanta ver esa imagen por supuesto
me da orgullo estoy con ella no las
conozco pero pero estoy copia y con mis
primas que están luchando allá yo aquí
ellas allá pero no no no las conozco
porque realmente todo lo que hago es en
francia- canción y tengo un poco pocos
contactos y qué proyectos tiene tiene
otras
ellas preparadas en el cajón mi proyecto
número 1 es quedarme viva y no morir de
este virus y después no sé me gustaría
seguir escribiendo
pero no sé no sé muy bien en qué tiempo
como porque está teniendo muy buena
acogida el libro de momento a pesar de
la pandemia y de que estemos más o menos
confinados no está teniendo muy buena
acogida
tengo un contenta bueno pues muchísimas
gracias
elisa rojas por haber estado con
nosotros le deseamos muchísimo éxito y
antes de despedirnos quería preguntarle
si algún plan de traducir este libro
esta primera novela del francés al
español si alguna editorial por ahí a lo
mejor ya haya interesado algún plan
desde aquí me gustaría mucho que fuera
traducido en español porque piensa que
es un libro importante para las mujeres
con discapacidad y para todas las
mujeres entonces si hay un editorial que
le interesa que lleven al set porque yo
sé que están trabajando sobre ese
proyecto pues muchísimas gracias lisas
rojas y muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes por habernos acompañado ya saben
qué
en volver a ver y escuchar esta
entrevista en nuestras páginas web
rf y mundo.com y france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]